digamos que el precio actual en el
mercado para los contratos futuros de
compra de manzanas especifican la
entrega de 1000 kilos de manzanas el 20
de octubre y para simplificar los
cálculos vamos a decir que esto es
dentro de un año
y digamos que el precio actual de
liquidación para intercambios futuros
para la entrega en esta fecha es de 300
dólares y también vamos a asumir que el
precio actual en el mercado por 1000
kilos de manzanas para comprarlas hoy no
el 20 de octubre dentro de un año el
precio de hoy en el mercado actual es de
200 dólares y también vamos a asumir que
si queremos tener un préstamo de 200
dólares tenemos que pagar un interés del
10% anual si queremos tener 200 dólares
ahorita dentro de un año tendremos que
pagar 220 dólares y con todos estos
parámetros que acabamos de ver hay
alguna manera de tener una ganancia sin
riesgos una forma de arbitrar esta
situación y como se podrán imaginar en
efecto si la hay lo que podemos hacer es
tomar prestados 200 dólares vamos a
escribirlo acá tomar prestados
200 dólares y usar esos 200 dólares para
comprar 1000 kilos de manzanas
ahorita compramos 1000 kilos de manzanas
las mantenemos guardadas en un lugar
donde se mantengan bien y también nos
convertimos en los vendedores de este
contrato futuro o también podremos decir
que vendemos que hacemos la venta corta
en el futuro es otra manera de pensar en
ello así que nosotros nos convertimos en
los vendedores vendedores
el contrato futuro contrato futuro
especialmente lo que estamos haciendo es
acordar vender mil kilos de manzanas el
20 de octubre dentro de un año por 300
dólares y lo que quiero mostrarles es
que si tenemos todos estos parámetros
podemos garantizar que ganaremos dinero
sin importar qué es lo que suceda al
menos al precio de las manzanas por eso
se le llama un arbitraje si nos
adelantamos un año ahora ya ha pasado un
año y en un año definitivamente tenemos
los 1000 kilos de manzanas y para
mantenerlo simple vamos a asumir que las
manzanas no se pobre son unas súper
manzanas estas son manzanas que nunca se
echan a perder así que definitivamente
dentro de un año tendremos 1000 kilos de
manzanas así que doy las manzanas para
concretar el contrato de venta de hoy
las manzanas para concretar el contrato
y también tengo mi préstamo tengo mi
préstamo de 200 dólares que en cuanto
concretó mi contrato
voy a tener 300 dólares aquí así que
aquí tengo 300 dólares y lo que debo son
220 son los 200 dólares que me prestaron
más los 20 dólares de interés anual así
que a esto lo tengo que restar de mi
préstamo 220 dólares por lo que voy a
tener una ganancia garantizada libre de
riesgos de 80 dólares 80 dólares de
ganancia en un año y qué piensan al
respecto si este precio de liquidación
está por encima de 220 dólares voy a
tener una ganancia libre de riesgos una
forma de pensar sobre precios futuros es
que aunque ustedes crean que va a pasar
algo que las manzanas vayan a
desaparecer o hay una escasez de
manzanas
quizás el precio de las manzanas
aumenten dentro de un año siempre va a
haber una manera de arbitrar lo siempre
y cuando el precio de liquidación si el
crecimiento en el precio es mayor que
el costo de tomar prestada esta cantidad
de dinero el costo de tomar prestados
200 dólares el costo de tomar prestado
200 dólares es de 20 dólares por lo que
el precio de liquidación no debería ser
asumiendo que no hay arbitraje no
debería ser mayor que 220 dólares